first time I've ever done this huh how
does it start again
I'm a dance instructor extractor extract
that extract people rise and shine it's
in special time good morning believe
nation my name is Alex and my one word
is belong I believe the world would be a
better place if more people felt that
they belong let's start off the day
right together grab your coffee and sip
on today's message get experience over
to you
louis c.k the stage presence comes
pretty quickly depending on who you are
how to write jokes and how to generate
material and know what's gonna work that
sort of comes you know first ten years
you're building the skills yeah the
basic skills are white timing delivery
and timing and delivery and material
that works generating the jokes cuz most
comedians you know you write your own
stuff you come up with your own thing
connecting with an audience and then
there's all sorts of other things that
happen you know that your top your best
show keeps getting higher and higher
that's the first thing how good you can
do keeps increasing but then the really
important thing is how bad your worst
show starts coming up that's that I
think that's for any performer you know
your worst show needs to come up close
to the best show so that even on your
worst night you still get so in the new
season yeah your best show shouldn't the
the worst show should be be much closer
to margins should be like that yes right
yeah yeah how does that happen well the
experience is just experience it's just
say you know there's hardly any
situation that I that I haven't seen so
you know when I feel an audience you
know you get an instinct for things once
you get really good at the skills and
your bottom comes up you're able to go
try stuff that's probably not gonna work
and that's where you find that's where
you get more that's where you get better
and more interesting when you're you
know the good comics do that
it's not enough to get just experience
you need to analyze it to get better I
Love Lucy case message about making
mistakes and getting a ton of experience
what I found was missing from others
it's not enough just to get experienced
I'm a dance instructor and I want to be
the best instructor in the world I teach
four days a week actually I teach five
days a week
I teach about sixteen classes in a week
so I am always getting a lot of
experience but the thing I realized a
couple months ago was occasionally I
start toasting when people are laughing
when people are having a great time I
relax and I don't push myself as hard so
yes it's very important to have
experience to put yourself out there to
make yourself vulnerable to make
mistakes but you need to learn from them
and the only way you can learn from them
is to analyze what you're doing to get
better so I have instructors coming in
watching my classes and giving me
feedback I record myself teaching
classes and the night of I will go home
and I will look through the video to see
how I could have done better so if you
look at any famous comedian Louis CK's
Dave Chappelle Kevin Hart Chris Rock
Bailey I will just perform at the big
stage they go to the small stage the
performance small crowds they hone their
material they look at their audience to
get feedback what's funny what's landing
it's not enough for you to go out there
and make a bunch of mistakes because you
will get better but to be the best you
have to make sure you learn from your
mistakes you have to be active in your
performance aware of what you're doing
and looking for ways constantly to be
the best so the question of the day is
what's one area of your life you're
coasting in please leave it in the
comments below I also want to give a
quick shout out to David chunky soup
David thank you so much for purchasing a
copy of Evans book your one word it
really means a lot to us thank you so
much for watching we believe in you and
we hope you can seem to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
we see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso
I work spray so keep me go
who was the first guy that blew you off
stage I don't think I ever get blown off
I felt some heat in DC tear that at that
time you'd already left but Teddy carbon
and Teddy carpenter was one of those
yeah Teddy carbons want us do is they
would like like like really bring it to
you
I took some else I'll tell you got me
remember Chris Thomas yeah yeah
destroyed I'd only done stand-up like
four times and they were like we're
gonna put you know Chris Thomas by this
time must be doing stand-up like but
forty two years and they were like they
were gonna put Chris up next and then
again see literally goes you can go home
it was the worst I dry mouth Bob you
have a good bond so bandage thirsty
party that was fun but you were like I
think I think part of us because you
were like a young comic you didn't have
the experience of know how to transfer
that energy from one well that's exactly
what was the lack of experience so cut
to like years laters when we were all
doing like Def Jam tour def Comedy Jam
tours and we were Madison Square Garden
the show was Chris Thomas Chris Tucker
and they made me clothes
man I'm irked that was my Karate Kid
tournament night was like has your
process is an actor changed over the
years I have learned from each
experience you know what what works
better than something else so I think
experience helps it's helping me I
didn't really know what I was doing when
I started so it took a while for me to
figure it out they help you in playing
this role as a CEO experience I think
all of the experience I've had in life
within the film work and outside of it
is helped helps to prepare me to think
about a different kind of character if
we go back to somebody who's in that
beginning part of their career I think
the wrong advice to them would be say
just pick one of those things and that's
what everybody says all the time they're
always like oh you have you have to
focus you have to just pick your niche
or your niche you got to do that and how
are you really going to find that
combination of factors of joy money and
flow without expanding your options
without trying a lot of different stuff
so you did that you did that in your
career I did that and I think in the in
the beginning part of really trying to
figure out what am I good adds and also
not just what am I good at but what is
going to be rewarded you know in the
marketplace you know I said yes to a lot
of different things and so I always
encourage people when you're when you're
starting out expand your options do
everything that you can to have a lot of
different experiences and then as you
become more successful as you have more
experience than you limit the options
then you start being more selective then
you start being like okay I am going to
apply that litmus test more often I am
gonna say okay you know I've got I've
got all these different things I could
do what is most aligned what where can I
have the most convergence you know what
am I really like getting close to how am
I gonna have the biggest impact in the
world but I don't think you can
necessarily do that when you're just
getting started because you don't know
[Music]
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
up or so it would be like a little
beacon hey believe nation if you want to
know what the most important one word is
for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details